Linux in open source operating system
that makes it possible for humans to
play with computers it was created in
1991 by University of Helsinki student
Linus Torvalds his goal was to create a
free version of the Minix operating
system which itself was based on Unix
today it's used everywhere like the vast
majority of web servers embedded apps
like your smart TV mobile devices
running Android and is by far the best
choice for your personal computer with
many different distros to choose from
like Debian Arch and Fedora just to name
a few just like Windows or Mac OS Linux
is an operating system that manages a
computer's memory and processes allowing
Hardware to communicate with software
when you fire up a Linux machine a
bootloader will first put the system
into memory at its core we have the
kernel which is like a seed from which
the rest of the operating system grows
it's divided into multiple smaller
subsystems like a process scheduler
device drivers and a memory manager
they're exposed with a system call
interface which itself is wrapped with
the c standard Library which provides an
API that user applications can interact
with now beyond the kernel we have
applications that make the OS usable for
humans which are provided primarily via
the gnu project like a shell to interact
with the kernel from the command line
windowing systems on desktop developer
utilities and countless other
applications to get started install your
favorite Linux distro open the terminal
and notice how we're logged in as the
root user on a specific Linux machine
currently we're in the home directory of
the root user which is shortened to this
tilde character show its full name with
the print working directory command now
use change directories with a double
period to go to the root of the file
system use the ls command to print all
the subdirectories here these are your
critical system files let's go back home
with CD tilde now create a new file with
touch then edit it from the terminal
with a tool like VI Vim Nano or emacs in
Vim type Ida insert write your
screenplay hit Escape then colon WQ to
write it to the file system now use the
cat command to read the file if it's
really big use grep to find all the
lines in that file that contain in a
search term or pattern if we want to see
how big that file is we can enter the
disk usage command every file has an
owner and a set of permissions assigned
to it we can change the owner with the
Chone command or its permissions with
chamod now if your current user doesn't
have proper permissions you can put
super user do in front of any command to
run it with elevated privileges to
install new software on this machine we
can use a package manager like Advanced
package tool which will retrieve the
code from the cloud and place it in the
proper location on your system we just
went through a bunch of commands let's
recap everything with history this has
been Linux in 100 seconds if you want to
see more short videos like this hit the
like button and subscribe thanks for
watching and I will see you in the next
one